an anaconda mother is giving birth to
live babies because anacondas are among
the 30% of snake species that do not lay
eggs these 40 babies about a third of
her body weight are saying hello to the
wilds of Venezuela the mother also
expels about a dozen orange spheroids
these are eggs that never developed into
babies
although anacondas are the largest
snakes in the world this trim down
mother hasn't eaten in several months
you'll have to excuse her if she dines
on some of the eggs she's gotta eat
something so she'll be strong enough to
go out and hunt again some of her babies
are stillborn
she'll also eat those of course with 40
babies sometimes you might accidentally
taste a live one
whoops I'm sorry exactly once they're
out of moms body the babies are on their
own the first of the babies and slithers
off
the baby goes after its first meal but
when you're this young you tend to look
like a meal to other predators like
these piranhas for example at least the
Anaconda has stealth and pretty good
camouflage on its side the baby makes
its way through the water hyacinth ah
but then stealth fails and the baby
wanders into the open
it's a sad tale
now come on I mean they are piranhas
another baby races off to safety or not
like most cats ocelots
don't care for water that much but since
these anacondas aka water Boas prefer to
be in water more than any other type of
boa even staying submerged for ten
minutes at a time
the Ocelot has to adapt giant otters and
Caymans also prey on the baby snakes the
full-grown anaconda is one of the
world's most powerful predators and
grows up to dine on these same animals
that hunted it when it was young